foreign
oh yeah let me pull my screen up let's
let's see if it makes me more beautiful
I couldn't tell if I was out of focus or
not
I can't really tell that's the one thing
this
this that's just those that's just that
those 34 year old Taurus
hell no
don't you miss it
you're gonna start seeing bumps that you
had no idea you've ever existed 34 year
old pores you miss those and 34 year old
follicles too don't you God like things
just start connecting you're like I've
never knew that would even existed
hilarious
all right I've turned on auto focus
Maybe
this is a good way to start the show
though
for sure
is to be like
yeah that's why I do it manually because
of the auto focus all right great great
way to start the show
welcome to the tech feedback hour
where are we
there we go oh got it I think that
feels like Focus right there
[Music]
all right
oh look at that we already got pizza in
here
annoy keto Carol
goody what's goody
we're doing it type 5 feedback hour
or the joke going back hour yeah
welcome everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
so here we go
Jerry Kroll in the building
shout out to everyone that comes to this
every week without us promoting it I
mean y'all are the real winners like the
facts y'all show up knowing there isn't
a link knowing there isn't promo and you
know all you know is the time and even
then the time could the time could
is flexible
so we appreciate you all for hanging out
with us every week
despite
uh any of those professional things so
thank you all so much
we appreciate y'all yes for sure and
Jones in here from DC hello Joan
all right and I think we'll get out of
Mueller in the new year is what I think
it's gonna be a running joke
every time I do his voice next week
but I think I think
I think for the rest of the year we're
gonna ride it out and then I think next
year we'll start bringing on some peeps
um Ricky glor for sure to drop a new
special with comedy Dynamics so he
reached out about coming on so we'll
we'll start having some peeps on in the
new year but I think for the you know we
only have a few weeks left in the year
we'll just stick to this format
for sure
you know
yeah it's easy
we
next year I'm gonna put it on my vision
[Laughter]
and this is what he's thinking
all right
all right believe it when I see it
fellow funnies all right aaronore
we know
is this aaronore's first time I don't
know if I
oh
um I don't remember recognize him from
others we've done
which is very exciting
there we go now I can be yellow
so welcome
we are doing
um
the joke feedback hours so do post your
jokes in here if you'd like some
feedback on them yoshin have a couple
Tails from the road we're gonna share
with y'all
uh beforehand and um shout out to
everyone in Seattle I had uh Joe
Dombrowski I just had him on the show
and then he did he did shows in Seattle
and said people came up to him talking
about hearing him on hot Breads so
nice that's always my favorite that's my
favorite when Comics that were on the
show were like yo the hot breadth of
verse is ouch yeah
yeah yeah I love that
that's always good
yeah always feels good
to hear the hot breadth verse in action
[Music]
doing it
so um
both of you both of us did holiday
parties this weekend
yeah holiday parties
I went up to Charlotte and did one
and you were here in Atlanta doing one
for no big deal Mercedes-Benz
uh corporate no big deal
um I'm not sure who should go first
uh oh how do you go first I can go first
yeah yeah go ahead
um
or do you want me to go first I can I
can go first mine
mine's um
more mine's brief I guess I mean I went
to Charlotte uh it was a 1pm gig
um
that's a blessing right there that's
what we working towards baby
1pm show but it was in Charlotte which
means I was up at like
six to leave at seven to get to the show
on time
okay which means get to the show on time
means get there early
eat in the car which for all my road
dogs out there we had some sardines
some canned sardines
that loud pack of uh sardines and um
some trail mix
as well
and uh a quest bar so a real nice
balanced meal
which pre-pandemic when I was like
living on the road I made videos of me
eating like sweet potatoes with tuna I
would have like a baked sweet potato and
I would mix tuna in it
um I had boiled eggs that I put in the
hotel fridge and the hotel fridge was
too cold so it froze the eggs so I have
a video of me eating frozen hard-boiled
eggs
in my and after after I posted it my
wife then mowed me and said
get my real lunch
oh
which was funny
um so yeah so this was this is one of
those Road gigs you know um it was a
corporate gig so those are those are the
gigs that make it all worth it when when
you when that check clears but still we
lived on the edge baby I love that road
grind so I was eating sardines before
the gig in my car changed in the car all
those good things
um
the gig was the gig went well
well enough
um I mean it was one it's a holiday
party so they can be hit or miss so like
the audience was fun but it was like
okay haha next joke haha next joke haha
next like there wasn't any there wasn't
any momentum it like you know if you do
a set long enough it'll start to build
and you can get some roll as we call it
in the game but it was really like every
joke
you had to reprove yourself for 45
minutes like I thought I thought by you
know 10 15 minutes in I was like all
right we'll get in there but every
single one was like all right next all
right next all right next yeah yeah
um
but they really liked the they really
liked um
like the crowd work and stuff and I need
to I need to be better at
remembering to have fun on stage I was
talking
uh
afterwards with the comic that opened
and it it was just like because he
struggled too and he he was at the point
he's been doing a few years but he's at
the point we were talking after to where
if a joke misses that he then addresses
it and then like try like instead of
just go like you just want to keep going
and the audience will come to you but
when you're young if a joke misses then
you feel like you gotta address it and
be like oh I guess you didn't like that
one okay she didn't like this one either
so he was at that point
um yeah but we were talking afterwards
about just remembering to have fun and
like I was having fun with the audience
and they were liking it but then I was
in my head about but this is stand up
and I gotta remember to do my material
so I kind of kept going in and out of
that
um and it was a good reminder this just
I mean at the end of the day just have
fun your job is to provide a fun show
and if they want to be more interactive
then let that be what the show is
absolutely
yeah that's good man that's a bunch of
purist though you know yeah yeah for
sure we we get you know we get in our
booty I have my gig
um last week uh it was it was a good gig
I'd give it you know I I I'm I don't lie
to myself about sort of how I do I'd
give myself sort of like a B minus for
the gig overall
um and I'll say a B minus uh mostly
because like so after every gig I'll
always do like an evaluation you and I
have talked about this I don't know if
I've shared it on a hot breath what I
did well what I didn't do well and what
I could improve on the next time
um every gig
I always do that
and and do it like immediately after
like before I start crying in the car uh
immediately after
[Laughter]
I didn't I didn't I would I would say
like I didn't cry this time but
definitely there was like a throw up
coming I was just like
oh we've all been there
uh it was just it did not feel good in
the bodies my kneecaps started hurting I
was like do I have arthritis or is this
just just not a great set that I had so
I'll say overall what what else is that
I actually wrote like a completely like
a new 20 minutes for
the gig because I was hired to roast
them so this is Corporate people
and this bottle maybe like
between 10 to 15 people in the room
and I wrote jokes for all of them pretty
much and maybe like uh Road jokes for
every single person
and basically like I had bios on them
like background stuff wrote jokes for
every single person and my you know my
set was supposed to be like 40 to 45
minutes so 20 minutes was meant to be
roast and then another 20 minutes was
meant to be like
my stuff and I really didn't like redo
my stuff or like go over my stuff I just
know my material it's 20 minutes like I
have enough to know what I can go in and
out of and usually like I would say the
way I typically do my set is I know my
first joke and I know my closer
everything kind of in between is based
on how audiences like react to stuff so
like the first couple jokes I'm just
kind of like I'll say this is something
that Drew Thomas taught me not like
physically taught me but like I watched
him do like a weekend and the first
couple like five minutes of a set he's
just like working the audience
and then the rest of this set is built
on how they react to things he's asking
questions are y'all all this other stuff
so I I've done that mostly probably for
the last couple years that I don't have
like a set list unless I want to get
stuff out but it's mostly like first
joke last joke but everything in between
is just stuff from the joke list that I
could go to but with this show so like
the first 20 minutes of it so like the
roast stuff
it was pretty decent like it was I'd
give it like a b b plus
um
part of this part is just like I didn't
have a microphone
what in a room that was just like
yeah I didn't have a microphone I was in
a room that was like a long table but it
was a long table like one of those
conference room tables at like a
restaurant but then
so there were seven people on one side
that was pretty much
back to me as I was performing
right the other thing was like this was
like a surprise gig
only two people knew that there was
going to be comedy oh
the person that basically booked it and
then the per the uh basically in essence
I mean the big dog let's put it that way
the biggest of the big dogs
it was kind of his surprise he was like
oh let's comedy in this person's
birthday
basically so no one else knew so as I
walked as I walked in
everyone stops their conversation and
it's just like who are you
like I am here's the thing I'm wearing
like a super nice suit right like I'm
I'm I'm Dapper as hell right
but like I come in as they're just in
the middle of having conversations and
then I
reset whatever is happening in the room
to then perform
so I'm the comedian we're gonna have a
comedy show
uh get ready to laugh I'm here to roast
you and here's the crazy part like my
first like
thing was to be like I can't do this
without the mic so I brought a mic and
just had
like get in but it was just a mic just
to hold I was just like I can't just
talk like no can't like this this feels
natural when I'm on the stage just doing
this I I can't do that like on a stage
without like hands or whatever so I
brought like a basically a fake mic just
to like perform
so that's how the set started right and
to your point
every single every even like oh my God
even the jokes that I did have right so
I bought my iPad because I didn't like
memorize the entire 20 minute set like I
had like a month and a half and a half
so
uh so I had stuff but I knew them right
so I'm going through the iPad and I'm
touching each person I'm just like Bam
Bam Bam but everything to your point had
to be reset ha
do that funny thing again and then it
was just like it I had to reset the
whole
over and over again
so even that part I was I was getting
through it and like you know some
laughed some not laughing but what I
recognize is they did a lot more talking
amongst themselves
after I did a joke about them so there
was just a lot of like chitter chatter
based on the joke
but because they're friends and like
they know each other
so it was actually a good thing but the
thing that I recognized is I didn't pick
up on that
and I wish I would have just leaned into
like my improv skills and just like did
more and improvise more
instead of what I did do was like just
trying to get through those jokes I was
like I need to just get through these
jokes that I wrote These jokes that I
worked on so I can go into my material
that I'm comfortable with
right that's for sure gonna work
yeah that for sure is going to work and
then as soon as I start into my set
I'm like
they're not feeling none of it like
zero connection to anything and this
like and I think I re I also like I also
try to like evaluate some of the stuff
that I was saying and I recognize that I
touch on topics that are very that could
be very uncomfortable for corporate
people to talk about when you have high
level people in the room there's this
concept in Corporate America called the
hippo have you ever heard the hippo uh
is
the highest paid person in the office
and there's this concept kind of like
when you when we do shows right and you
see that uh like a husband and wife
where the husband will look at his wife
to see if he's La if she's laughing and
then he'll laugh at the joke if it's
like a sexual it's like a like some kind
of uncomfortable joke or whatever
that's how they were about all a lot of
my jokes I talk about race here's the
thing here's what I recognize I talk
about race I talk about poop I talk
about being uncomfortable I talked about
all these things at dinner
right before they were supposed to have
like cake and dessert
I think it was very much like why are we
talking about like poop and race and all
these like
I think it was just uncomfortable dinner
conversations
but
comedy setting
I would have destroyed
but in this setting of like super like
these aren't like low-level Executives
this is top of the food chain Executives
and
they just were not into
any of my material whatsoever but I also
like recognized that I didn't really set
them up to be into my material because
they don't knew nothing about me all
they really knew is I'm a comedian right
and even in some of the stuff that I
roasted them I talked a little bit about
myself but I would have I wasn't trying
to give much away so I did my set as if
though I was in a comedy room but what I
really recognize is this whole room is
not set up as a Comedy Room
like it was just not the right place for
me to do my hot 20. you know what I'm
saying like in a normal setting this
would have been great but man so
I think my hot 20 I mean here's the
thing I got through about 15 minutes I
went to my closer
uh
uh and they were not feeling the closer
and I was just like
oh
hey guys thank you so so much I have
been Yoshi in the middle of it
no yeah yeah like yeah as I was getting
into it
they weren't feeling like the opener to
my closer is funny they weren't into it
the midsection of my clothes was even
funny they weren't like they weren't
to any part of it but that's kind of how
it went all the way through like I got a
couple of laughs like here and there but
it was not consistent for sure my last
20 minutes was a certified bomb
certified
yeah yeah first trip yeah there was no
feeling there was no there was no qualms
about it it was like I was pulling
trying to pull stuff out of that
audience
um and they just were not
feeling it and so the funny thing is I I
ordered some food right beforehand so I
can like get it to go dude I walked out
of that place did not turn around I was
like I don't right afterwards
yeah yeah I didn't get the [__] I just I
just I just I left as fast as possible
because here's the thing here's what I
recognized and the thing I've got to
work on so this is the other thing yeah
the thing I need to work on is like
better about confronting like the
awkwardness even as a professional
like I realized I need to lean into my
um improv skills but I should have made
the show much more Interactive that's
the thing that I'll do better is not try
to just get through the material that
they asked me to do but actually play
with it where I could have actually
injected my jokes as part of the actual
set
what they were actually enjoying versus
do their material that they basically
asked me to write for and then do my
material I should have just interjected
the whole thing kind of like together
all the way through
and I should have like
been a bit more interactive with them
and asking why they were laughing at
certain things because there are certain
things that I said that like hit a nerve
I would have loved to get their feedback
and see if I could like make more fun of
some of that stuff as well so like I
think the key for me what I can do
better is lean into my improv and
listens listening skills overall and not
be so hell-bent on just trying to get to
my material
that's so funny that we almost
um had the same takeaway for both of our
gigs in a sense
my takeaway wasn't good I just want that
I mean my takeaway was not bombing I
said it went very well I just want you
to know I have a very high standard so
it can always be better but I just my
takeaway was not that I bombed but
it's funny that we're both like we need
to remember to have more fun in the
moment and understand the context of the
show we're performing at
the context the room the audience right
yeah like how did you perform in front
of
oh it's maybe like
70 Maybe
70. okay I performed in front of 12
people yeah in a restaurant essentially
in a restaurant in a box
where I'm just yelling jokes you weren't
expecting
they weren't expecting I'm yelling jokes
that I'm telling them this stuff is
funny yeah I mean
[Laughter]
your restraint like because I know this
gig
um like that you're talking about
um and like people flew in for like this
dinner like
this was like a big event for like high
level Executives at Mercedes-Benz
without a microphone people
people had to get passports to come to
this thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
some people had
these people had to get clearance from
the from the government to come through
and then they did not know that there
was going to be
a tall immigrant comedian at their show
[Laughter]
before their dessert like guys can you
stop talking
yeah and so there was just like I think
that's the thing that it was like
after the almost throw up in the car
like I took some time like the sleep was
not good it probably took me like I I
think I was
I was probably depressed from it maybe
for like a good
like
half a day wait hold on you cut after
that even your internet wasn't impressed
for a second you cut out and you were
like I got depressed and then you like
froze like the internet's like don't go
there Yoshi don't go there
it was I said a good half a day so a
good half a day I was just like in my
feelings about this gig
and then when I got out of that I was
very much like all right let's do some
true assessment yeah of what could have
been you're around it I think I was just
so I think here's what hurt my feelings
the most
as I was like I journaled afterwards is
that my material was the one that bombed
um I was like what in the world you know
what I'm saying like that was like a
shot to the heart but I recognize oh we
weren't really doing comedy
I was roasting them
that was the gig the gig was to roast
them I could have just interjected my
jokes all the way through
and they would have known the difference
you know what I'm saying like they would
have just been like he's funny and I
could have just did that all the way
through but when I saw it I was like oh
I'm a dude and here's the thing I was
like I got I was advised that this was
like the approach to take but I also
recognize it
even like agents
they don't know comedy in that way of
what happens in a room in a setting in a
box setting you know what I'm saying
yeah at a restaurant that no one knows
what's happened like they don't have
that context so you have that comments
going into it
I didn't have that context going in I
didn't know what I was going to get into
another lesson of like making sure you
know every detail of the event before
you get there what's the setting how
many people like all of that will help
in the preparations
sure I think the diff the biggest
difference that I know I would have done
it's from the top
I would have told everyone to turn
around and put their phones down we're
gonna do comedy like I would have
differently other than just going and
just because I kind of had to talk over
them a little bit but I also didn't have
a microphone without a mic to kind of
like hey
you can see like it was just this thing
like what they didn't know so I had to
set the expectation of what is happening
that that was one of the biggest things
I was like oh
I gotta learn how to like and here's the
thing I've I host a lot
yeah but I host rooms that like know
that there's gonna be comedy never
really done a room that didn't know that
comedy was gonna happen where everyone
was so I didn't know it was going to be
a surprise I thought they know that it
was coming and they'd look forward to it
that there was
you say when did you realize it was
going to be a surprise
when I arrived at the restaurant like oh
mind you arrived at the restaurant
uh two hours early yeah delayed it by
another hour Yeah by another hour and a
half
so I'm in the car just like going over
jokes right so just the tension keeps
building building while I'm like in the
car waiting but that's when they told me
so like
it was like oh no one knows that they're
gonna get roasted
it's like wait what that's what he said
when you got there like the guy was like
by the way this is a surprise yeah
yes
and in my head I'm like oh
in my head that was like
oh I gotta work hard for this
yeah yeah I I look I learned that lesson
I did a baby mama baby shower
and it was booked by the mom of the girl
that got knocked up
and in hindsight this was seemingly like
um a well-to-do this seemed like an
affluent white family and she got
knocked up by a black guy
and his family was there some of them
wearing like football jerseys and stuff
so it clearly seemed like a culture
Clash where this girl just was gonna
hook up with this guy and end up getting
knocked up so the mom wanted me to come
perform
for the baby mama baby shower and she
told me ahead of time everyone was super
excited and all this and then I got
there she's like oh come over here and
it was a surprise nobody knew I was
gonna be there especially the baby mama
who and I pull I show up with my speaker
and my microphone and I'm ready to go
but basically one of her friends after
I'm there I'm like hiding behind the bar
they had to like hide me
um and then so basically her friend goes
up like her mom introduces me to one of
her friends like oh this is the guy
who's gonna come like roaster and I was
like roast I thought I was doing comedy
I thought I was just doing stand up a
long story short the friend goes up
introduces me and then I go up there and
I'm supposed to do 20 minutes
I'm in a pool house it's like three in
the afternoon I have a I have my little
speaker in my microphone
nobody knows it's supposed to happen I
look like I look like uh like a tax
attorney or something like I look like
someone about to serve papers on child
support
the baby the the chick did not she was
not impressed she was on the couch just
give me this look the whole time it's
like oh yeah
it was a spite hire her mom it was a
spite hire for sure like I was picking
up the Vibes of like oh she got knocked
up and her mom's not happy and this is
her punishment paying me 300 to come
hate myself for 20 minutes
I'll I would do it again but not for 300
but it was a local gig so that's not bad
for you know in town work
but this was a few years ago
so I learned that lesson then of like
get all the details up front
yeah but the check cleared yeah yes
absolutely
[Laughter]
oh my God that's so hilarious
uh but yeah I mean it was a it's a good
lesson
just to be more in the moment yeah I
think we've we've done this long enough
to like remember that like you know and
also you know always go into a thing
like every gig there's us like a couple
of things that I want to always remember
and I think having fun
needs to always be at the top of that
list
yes but there's times that I remember it
and then times I don't remember it but
when I do remember it the gig always
goes well
like to remember to have fun
supersedes like most things even if I'm
not have I'm not the jokes aren't like
Landing if I remember to have fun
it turns it for me yeah or anything else
these aren't Landing all right let's
let's try some if a joke isn't Landing
if I'm having fun I'll try a new bit in
the middle of a set just because I'm
gonna have fun so and the best part is I
think that comes off more authentic and
the audience actually Vibes with you
so is that the oh unless clay Palace
what range should corporates be paying
I don't want to throw out a specific
number just because each one's different
but I would say in the thousands
yeah you should be getting four figures
for corporates yes yes four to five
yeah oh five yeah hey more yeah I'll
just say yeah at least at least four
figures for like a corporate event
um now ER for young Comics listening I
mean you know you may work your way up
to that
um and you may take some like I did I've
done things for Less before early in my
career but once you get to like
professional level where this is your
career and you're providing like this is
your livelihood then um yeah I think
four figures is definitely where the
corporate range is
um so where uh so the big takeaways if
we want to encapsulate it number one
have fun
remember to have fun
yes that's a big circle I'd say number
two read the room like I think like
don't forget to like actually engage
with the audience more than just
delivering of the jokes I think at the
end of the day the jokes are always
going to be there
but if you're having fun and engage in
the audience and keeping the audience in
mind
you do yourself a bigger favor by
actually paying attention to them
yes and I think read the room can also
have a part two of like know the context
of the room like so this could be at a
corporate gig of like okay what is the
company like what are they known for
what do they do what do they stand for
what like before before I did my show
I like looked up rkw residential got a
feel for their company culture their
mission their Vision what they've been
up to this year knowing the context that
way
but also the context of like if you're
an open mic okay what is this a weekend
show at 8 pm in Prime Time who's in the
audience does this look like date night
or is it a Tuesday at 11 at an Irish Pub
they don't even expect comedy at and
it's just like the town drunks there
it's like reading like knowing the
context of all the shows you do can help
determine your performance and also the
feedback you're going to get at that
performance
yeah absolutely I will say the other
um this is a good hindsight thing for me
even if you share your stuff with
Booker's agents
it doesn't mean that the people on the
other end have actually seen it or know
what's about to like your material
I didn't do anything different
materially than what I showed on tape
um
but I would just say the booker was just
like ah I knew you were funny I didn't
even watch it
you know what I'm saying so just
remember in your mind you might have
thought oh yeah they know this stuff
they've seen it they may not have even
at the corporate level but at the same
time the corporate stuff also gets much
more scrutinized so they actually when
you like they want clean
ings like
clean clean like oh yeah nothing
that HR could like be in on yeah I mean
I mean even if you have clean race
material like race in a in like a
corporate environment can be divisive or
whatnot like
yeah there's like there's different
there's different levels to clean
um so that's another thing of context
like you really want to know is anything
off limits are there topics I shouldn't
say are like you want all that
information up front to help set
yourself up for the best show possible
and it's fair to them to do that as well
absolutely
yeah man whoa
you brought you brought back memories of
that baby mama baby shower I had I
hadn't reflected on that in a minute
but yeah
and that was um
I booked that one on gig salad because
people ask me about corporate stuff so
there's stuff like gig salad and The
Bash and thumbtack you can make profiles
on
and um most of most of my corporate
stuff is Word of Mouth
for sure like that's that's where most
of like when people ask about corporate
work a lot of it is Word of Mouth
referral the one I did in Knoxville I
like messaged a friend on LinkedIn I
went to college with
and they were having a holiday party I
like message people about it I did like
a lot of cold Outreach that way
um so if you're wanting to book some
look at your immediate Network do you
have friends or family that own or work
at companies that may be doing a
corporate event or something like that
and kind of start with your inner circle
then work out from there
but most of it will come from people you
already know and it'll come when you're
ready
yeah very very true it all takes time
use your circle use your network
networking is a big part of the comedy
game
um
and as much as people want to focus on
jokes that's not the only it's a
business yeah
yeah no that's such a good point of just
like
these gigs are not they're not easy to
come by but you're likely going to get
them from somebody you already know
that's the reality
so just be patient my friends you will
find
you will get them
all in due time
whoo
all right let's get to these jokes
joke feedback time
hilarious
all right
that was a good one though yeah dude it
was great it was a good lesson
always yeah each show is a lesson
yep and then the good thing is like two
days later I had another gig that helped
me erase the memory of that gig
and there we go it's all yeah that's all
the the ups and downs of this comedy
game
yep
we all go through it that's
all right let's get to the gym
the fact nobody knew
oh there was going to be a show you're a
stranger without a microphone roasting
high level Executives
people that flew in for this event are
like what is hap what is happening yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you could tell there
was just some people that weren't into
it some people were just like wanting to
go back to their conversation they were
in the middle of conversation when it
just
it's like
you know how DJ scratches and then yeah
we got somebody in the building you know
what I mean like that's what happened
except I wasn't Jay-Z you're saying
right yeah yeah
like if it was like Trevor Noah they
would have been like hell yeah but it's
just Yoshi just this guy mind you they
didn't introduce me I introduced my damn
self hilarious
[Music]
gosh I love it
oh
me sometimes
let all lessons learned all right
so should we should do some jokes what
do you say
yeah yeah give some joke feedback we
have a hard stop because I got a gig
tonight yeah when do you need to stop
uh probably like 6 15-ish all right well
that all right all right all right good
we have a hard stop that's great okay
and we have a timer so we can get
through this yeah yeah and we'll we'll
we'll run through them but we hope that
was at least um
somewhat helpful and um
helping give some point of view that
even us as professional comedians you
know these are all
this is all part of the uh part of the
job we like to share with you all the
the side of the job people normally
don't share that's what this is all
about well I'll I'll say also say as you
like get ready for the first joke
um
the big thing at least from a mental
perspective for me
is
do whatever you can to get over that
bomb very very quickly
yeah so how did you bounce back because
you said only half a day I used to be
like depressed for like a week dude when
I would like bomb or didn't go well
you know what I recognize is like I
maybe this is just me because I'm a
parent
like when I got home like the sleep was
so I said half a day the the thing was
in the evening
uh you know I didn't cry myself to sleep
but it wasn't great uh
right but like sleep was tough because
it was the only thing on my mind and
then the next day
I'd probably say what like help me get
over it it's honestly just like looking
in my kids faces and realizing they
don't give two shits about whatever
happened they're just like enjoying life
and like just coming back to reality yes
that happened it sucked
we move on
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
they're never going to understand the
context why is Daddy so depressed right
now they're like they don't care they're
like Dad you want to play you know I
mean like that's all like they care
about so I think for me that was the
context that helped me get over it like
oh it was just like you had a bad night
you're gonna have a bad night every once
in a while as long as you don't have a
bunch of bad nights you know what I'm
saying yeah
and I haven't had that in a very long
time so just coming back to like reality
check
made it easier and then I realized oh I
gotta work on the next thing that I'm
doing
like if I focused on the last thing
mental isn't able to actually go to the
next thing which I want to be good
you know what I mean yeah and so that
was how I you know that that's what took
me out of that space was like oh I got I
got more stuff that I gotta do so it
wasn't another corporate gig actually it
was another corporate gig using a
totally different side of my skill set I
was hosting and DJing nice I still had
to prepare for that anyway so like just
remembering going to the next thing but
you'd want your mindset into the next
thing not on the thing that you know you
weren't happy about
yeah so even if you don't have a family
and something to live for just remember
that you survived you know so even if
you're feeling bad about the gig just
know okay maybe that wasn't as bad as
I'm reflecting on it and focus on what
did go well and if what did go well is
that hey you got to perform it could be
the bar is that low and you start to
stack the Gratitude from there so first
turn on the positive side it will help
you get over it and getting on stage as
quickly as possible will help you bounce
back quicker as well
yeah I'll say this even though in my
mind
I remember the last bomb that I had
um I remember counting how many laughs
happened
and I could count it like on my hands
and in this show
it was much more than just hands you
know what I'm saying like it was more
laugh so also put in perspective that
even though I wasn't crazy about it I
know that they laughed for
a lot of the time that I was there you
know what I'm saying so like just like
remembering you know it may not have
been bad we're all very self-deprecating
as comedians to ourselves and our own
sets so
it's usually never as bad as you think
it is and it's usually Never As Good as
you think it is either
so just remember that my friends
all right
hey Adam Mueller next year baby oh we're
doing it
all right
for sure I'm so excited about it too
it's gonna be great
um so yeah let's get into some jokes
here get into jokes
um first joke and we have a heart out
um but
um we want to get to as many jokes as
possible here
so first up we have Tavis Aikman
um
I was laid off from my job and I finally
know what my exes felt when I broke up
with them relief that I don't have to
fake it anymore
okay I like it
yeah
um I think the only thing I would add is
just some context maybe around like
the job
um
that probably the only thing because
then
I just want to know more that you felt
relief like
because a job could have made you happy
or it could have been like
I just think I'm missing the context of
what kind of job it was so I'm missing
some specificity
yeah and it's
I don't know if the misdirect broke up
with him relief broke up with them pause
relief
that I don't have to fake it anymore
I wonder if like I can quit faking it or
I don't know something a little bit
quicker like that I don't have to fake
it anymore it feels a bit wordy
yeah
but I like it overall though
yeah that's a good joke well done nice
Tavis thank you
um
jokihotic
yeah I just started dating an escape
artist I'm just worried I'm gonna have
to I'm gonna have trouble tying her down
all right let me do that again
fifth grade reading no no not Miss Smith
I'm not going to do it
I started dating an escape artist I'm
just worried I'm gonna have trouble
tying her down
I just don't know if tying her down and
uh dating or correlated enough like I
see the word player trying to do but I
don't know if tying her down applies to
dating as much so if there could be
another example
tied up escape artist feeling trapped
claustrophobic
um lonely
uh I also think there's no emotion to
this joke
okay
it feels like it feels like just a word
play just for the sake of word play
so like if you said tying her down to
marry me
then we know like you're serious about
her like there's no like emotional
connection to like why you be tying her
down that's it yeah and tying her yeah I
think there could be more context in the
tying her down so like you said tying
her down to marry me
um oh I cracked myself up said
uh able to lock her down
yeah Robert Brown said tying the knot
um that's funny
yeah yeah
oh yeah aaronore said proposing for
marriage yes there's some good ones in
there
nice
yeah
nicely done though yeah I got some good
feedback in the comments as well
um
keto Carol
uh I recently took in a rescue and was
really shocked at how expensive he is
bag of food fresh haircut and a box of
Magnums who knew it it was so expensive
to re-home a man
foreign
I like this I actually think the only
thing I would change is like my
boyfriend at end rather than a man
rather make it generic like make it
personal because the rescue feels like
obviously you're going for rescue like
an animal yeah but make it personal like
to re-home like
my husband or re-home my boyfriend
and it seems like
if the if the game of this joke is
really about how he's a rescue
then what are other things associated
with rescuing an animal
that could be with rescuing
um he had all his shots
um he came with paperwork
yeah yeah the box of condoms I'm not
sure it hits versus like something that
might be more related to like a litter
box I think would be
um
yeah yeah I like that I know I see where
she's going with the condoms but it
doesn't but a rescue Magnums aren't um
like doesn't connect with a rescue and
the game of the joke is about the Rescue
game
yeah
um so it need to be more related to that
yeah nice
yeah or like pissing with his leg up or
something yeah house trained house
broken something like that you're
trading would be funny potty training
yeah yeah yeah
nice thanks Carol
Hannah
fact of life if you wake yourself up
with a storm the first thing you do is
you look around to see who's laughing at
you
fact of life
if you wake yourself up with a snoring
the first thing you do is you look
around to see who's laughing at you
so right now it's like a statement we
need like a misdirect of sorts or some
sort of like it's kind of just like a
phrase right now
I think it's more like ah you see you
look around see who's laughing at you
because I get what she's trying to do
with the fact that someone snores
um but
foreign
the first thing I do is look around to
see who's laughing at me
so that that can help to personalize it
a little bit and then if you maybe if
Hannah acts it out where she does she
does wake herself up snoring and then
she does like a thing like her house is
haunted or something
yeah could be something there yeah yeah
nice
uh Robert Plant said this sounds like
something Confucius would say hilarious
oh where Robert said falling asleep at
work or school yeah following the
location could add humor to it as well
where are you falling asleep
yeah that's a good point and hopefully
it's no one in your audience falling
asleep
hmm
[Music]
all right next joke
Harold
uh read in the news taking Viagra
reduces the risk of Alzheimer's by 70
percent the scientists conducting the
study was probably like all right boys
so it's 69 but people be thinking we
trolling
all right
read the news Viagra
69 I mean I see where you're going with
it
um
but there's no there's nothing about
Harold in here it's kind of like a
general phrase and it's kind of like a
69 joke at at the heart of it which
I don't know
doesn't really sing to me
this is one of those you can do better
yeah
like Harold's new Harold just started
hanging out with us which we appreciate
but we do like the challenge the comics
that hang out here of something more
personal to you something more personal
but also just recognize like even a sick
so here's the thing
especially with jokes extremes work
better that's what helps with the
surprise of the Assumption when you make
it is you'd go from 70 and you go to 69
that's not that huge of a surprise that
that it would come to that so always
just do like extremes would be better
then yeah I mean then it's like oh we
didn't see that coming 70 to 69 isn't
really that
surprising yeah yeah there's got to be a
surprise an exaggeration in One
Direction or another
noise
James
yeah I find it ironic that it's Prince
Harry not William that's losing air
[Music]
air
I guess is the word play there
there huh
um
so the hardest part about this is this
would be hard
spoken
in an audience so this is one that's
probably better as a tweet versus on a
stage
because it would be I'm not sure
everyone would get it as soon as they
heard it
that you're making the hair air yeah
yeah for sure
yeah you can't really see that you're
doing that word play
so it could work maybe on Twitter or
something but for stage I just I don't
see it translating but the word play is
there I see what you're doing there
James
um nice
thanks for sharing fam
oh and Robert said uh Viagra helps with
Alzheimer's but the real problem is
remembering it's been four hours
that's funny that's funny angle on that
one yeah yeah
uh Shane Cafferty
I've dated three girls who all have the
same tattoo of a snake wrapped around a
knife on their chest I've been dating
Voldemort's sister she who must not be
tamed
and then he has an act out
avocadady issues
I mean this is
as the opposite of the last choke this
is one of those that I can actually see
that I think would be funny with the act
out like um
daddy issues so I think you can pause on
where you say it yeah
but yeah that's funny
and there could be more magic joke of
like the the only magic trick was
um
we that that we lasted more than a month
or or like magic they disappeared or I
Disappeared there could be so there
could be more jokes around the theme of
magic or Harry Potter
for sure or like yeah like magic is I
lasted longer than their daddy did yeah
or that but unfortunately for us there
wasn't a sequel or something like that
you know
yeah yeah that's one of those videos
comes with Harry Potter and daddy issues
but that's funny though I like that Venn
diagram of like Harry Potter's and daddy
issues yeah like the girls you dated
have this that's very funny
yeah that's a fun one
um Jerry Crowell
my 86 year old dad told me his secret
for getting so many gates at his age
I can still drive at night
who's gonna kill at the nursing homes
Jerry's I found his demo baby
I found his demo
[Laughter]
hilarious
that's funny
I like it yeah I get it a person joke
old people can't drive yeah not bad
I don't think I have anything
yeah I think especially with that pause
there just making sure I can still drive
at night
um and then there may be other old
people tropes that yeah um I can still
drive at night
um but I need to be home by 7 PM yeah or
AARP he gets the ARP discounts on dates
um
yeah his life insurance Maybe
I think there could be I I it's not like
your dad's a character there Jerry I'd
love to hear more jokes about him
in general
all right
just the last couple are here
um aaronore
who said he's been watching from afar
this is his first time watching live so
here we go
um oh oh wait
is he tagging up
oh Robert Brown's aforementioned joke
ads meaning to hot breath comedy
all right all right well coming up next
thank you Aaron Orr we have
Robert Brown's joke
uh I'm too pragmatic to be sympathetic I
inherited my uncle's car nobody wanted
it because he died inside the car from
carbon monoxide poisoning That's tragic
but at least the Exhaust Works
oh
or at least it'll uh pass emissions or
um
passed out passing emissions
here's I I like the joke I don't think
we need so much context around nobody
wanted it because I don't think it
helped actually helps or neither just
that he died from
carbon monoxide poisoning but at least
the Exhaust Works plays well into the
fact that you're pragmatic
um
and I don't even think you need to you
could just say I'm so pragmatic I
inherited my uncle's car and that's the
joke the sympathetic part actually I
don't think is needed I think it's it's
telling in the joke that you're
pragmatic without being sympathetic so I
don't actually don't think we need it
because there's not a part where you're
not sympathetic about it if you don't
actually mention that
like anything really about being
sympathetic or you know I'm saying yeah
I like yeah I think just sticking with
pragmatic and I heard in my uncle's car
after he died in it from carbon monoxide
poisoning like you can just tighten it
up that way
yeah yeah I like that
hot breath
indeed aaronore
um so this may be the last one
he would have gotten a
big chuckle out of buttered ass if he
was here buttered ass
buttered ass
uh I think this may be the last one
cool
um
who read the last one did I read that
I read it okay
uh on dates I always ask the waiter's
opinion between two appetizers then
immediately order the one he didn't
recommend to assert dominance for the
remainder of the meal
[Laughter]
I like this only thing that we are
missing is what some kind of reference
to you
being like a dominant person or being
like I think you need to say I'm an
alpha so on dates I always ask the
waiter's opinion between two appetizers
then immediately order the other one so
I assert dominance for the rest of the
remainder of the meal we just need that
context of why you do this because it's
funny it's really funny because I can
imagine him coming back like do you want
dessert and then you'd be like which one
do you recommend
uh you just say you can say do you
recommend the ice cream or the
chocolate
ice cream well I get the chocolate and
then act that out of like how much
you're asserting your dominance yeah
yeah and Robert Brown said you could say
I don't ask for the soup of the day I
tell him
that's funny too
so I think there are yeah I think you
can get more detail about like the
specific appetizer you order or like
take it to dessert or I tip him uh like
with my fist or something like you could
maybe take it throughout the entire
order and there may be other word plays
within the ordering process you could um
you could add in there I mean I can even
imagine like I really like this premise
so that's why I'm going off on it on it
I can even imagine the the waiter being
like what would you guys like to start
with no we'd like to end with dessert
you mean like just anything he says you
just say the opposite to a certain
dominance yeah yeah yeah and I like the
context of adding that you like to be
Alpha like on a date like setting up the
the premise of the joke clearly
nice yeah that's so funny I don't ask
I don't ask about the soup I tell them
that is funny
it's like no no I'll tell you what the
specialist
[Laughter]
oh and um
real quick who scold asked our take on
accidental
or similar jokes
um I'll set a timer
but because we'll go all day but I mean
for me it's like parallel thought
happens all the time I think the easiest
way to eliminate it is to talk about
what's personal and unique to you that's
why we always encourage that because
we're all drawing from the same lives
and the same experiences Yoshi and I are
both married we have marriage jokes but
what makes them uniquely ours is talking
about our true experiences within
marriage so
no one can steal you
facts yeah I mean and I forget who said
this it was a
um
I don't know if you said it on the
podcast or I heard him somewhere else
Cedric the Entertainer
is mentioning something about he had
beef with like uh Katt Williams had a
problem saying that Cedric stole one of
his jokes
concentric was like tell me what jokes
and like they they figured it out or
whatever but he said you know in this
business if you feel like a joke has
been stolen right before yeah just
do do another one yeah um even uh what's
his name Carlos said that
um along on the on your on the podcast
you're just like oh people will always
be stealing he was like yeah you just
write more jokes yep because no one can
stop you being prolific around your joke
writing
exactly
yeah big facts very nice
let's land This Plane my friends we
appreciate you all so much for hanging
out oh my gosh
we did it again
we done did it again we do this every
Tuesday at 5 PM eastern time and then
every Wednesday at 10 A.M I'm back on
here doing a live joke writing contest
so come on back tomorrow morning y'all
yeah and we're sorry to Adam Miller that
we couldn't get him on the podcast but
we'll get them on the next one but we'll
we'll get you next time fam we'll get
you we'll get you in the new year I
promise we're doing it
no doubt about it 100 percent
and um
if y'all can't get enough
I did just drop a new video about the
world's richest comedian
that I'll I'll share
in the live chat if y'all would like
some more if y'all want some more comedy
goodies
there's one for you
um
but uh in the meantime in between time
you ready to land This Plane there Yoshi
let's do it baby this has been fun thank
you guys thank you for helping me talk
through uh my depression yes
but it's been good man I learned a lot
uh yeah this is awesome
don't forget to reach out to us if you
need anything but I'm always of service
we love this comedy game and ever forget
that yet loved it so if you need
something holla at your boys amen and
until next week y'all have a good one